hey guys how's it going so today we're
going to be unboxing the ps4 pro it just
came out this past week it's much more
powerful than the previous PlayStation
you cook like games and movies in 4k and
it's much more equipped to handle
PlayStation VR but of course if you did
get the VR headset you are totally fine
don't worry you do not have to upgrade
to the pro you're gonna be alright
before we get into this guy just a heads
up because this week is gonna be so
incredible for unboxings we've got the
new MacBook Pro with the touch bar
coming out hopefully tomorrow and later
on this week I'm going to be showing you
guys a new possible vlogging camera that
could be the ultimate vlogging camera
and all vlogging cameras I also got to
my left here as in comparison items to
compare to the ps4 pro this is the
PlayStation 4 this is the black ops 3
edition it's so beautiful and I miss
black ops 3 already a Nevada Nintendo 64
just because why not
it's sharp real sharp that slid through
there like butter spectacular graphics
enhanced gameplay extraordinary
entertainment wheels and little quick
start directions that's the things going
on in here
we are what's this
let's see what we've got in this box
first you've got some cords cords cords
cords
Oh a nice controller great just leave
HDMI headphones a USB mini charger let's
take a peek at this little bad boy this
is cute they have like a little tiny
PlayStation buttons here for kind of
like the stand to stand it up on I
thought it was gonna be a lot slimmer
I just initially thought it was gonna be
smaller but clearly it's definitely not
smaller Oh a lot
here's size comparison of a top-down
view it's like this much it's it's a lot
bigger actually let's compare it to the
ship 264 this in case you're curious
here's controller the same exact
controller that you guys are used to
seeing
headphones you've all seen those before
nice little micro USB cable to charge
HDMI power cable here's the Xbox one s
here's the to standing up side-by-side
it's a little tough damn you there one
thing that I do like is they have a
bigger power cable because for whatever
reason I'm not sure if you guys have
this problem but on every PlayStation 4
that I have used mine included my
friends anytime I go to like plug it in
it doesn't feel like it actually is that
snug inside of the back of the
PlayStation so I feel like this is a
little bit more substantial so hopefully
that will resolve that issue that I've
had
so let me know if that this happened to
you guys because I thought I was just
going crazy but maybe not well I look
forward to some really fun videos that I
have for you guys this week so let me
know in the comments below what you guys
think of the ps4 Pro are you getting one
what do you think
and what games have you been playing I'm
also curious to see what you guys think
of Call of Duty infinite warfare I have
been playing a lot more remastered
instead of a warfare so I don't know
what that's saying I'm still a big Call
of Duty fan but hmm yeah I see you guys
in the next video I look forward to
seeing you guys tomorrow for hopefully a
Macbook unboxing fingers crossed
I'll see you guys well I think you can
see Mike Christine hi look they actually
look really good on you like with your
hair everything so fit really fit well
like this Douglas feels really good yeah
what what